[Musique]
c'est sans doute la première fois que la
représentation nationale
reçoit officiellement
et collectivement des acquitté dans une
affaire judiciaire
[Musique]
l' affaire d'outreau c'est un événement
judiciaire en raison du fiasco
judiciaire qui a subi cette affaire qui
a duré quand même pendant quatre ans de
2001 à 2005
dans ma tête j'avais imaginé si nous
pouvions diffuser cette commission ça
allait être une sorte de feuilleton
quotidien pendant au moins 3 4 mois et
ça a été le cas l'assemblée nationale se
devait de vous exprimer son émotion face
au drame que vous avez vécu mais il nous
incombe aussi d'en tirer des leçons pour
éviter qu'un tel désastre ne se
reproduise est donc une manière un peu
culotté je suis allé trouver le
président debré c'est un ancien juge
d'instruction jeudi écoutez il faut que
cette commission soit public soit
transparente parce que les français
attendent des explications sur ce fiasco
judiciaire
qu'est ce qui me reste maintenant un
boulot de salariés et trois enfants
trois enfants d'autrui
la commission d' enquête a commencé je
crois le 10 janvier 2006 et s'est
terminée le 12 avril 2006 monsieur
fabrice burgaud je vais donc vous
demander maintenant de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure je le jure
je vous remercie
au bout d'une semaine tous les
journalistes toutes les chaînes sont au
101 rue de l'université
nous on a aimé la mèche quelque part le
résultat des courses c'est une audience
qui est montée je ne sais plus mais ça a
été
on dit devenue une grande chaîne
publique à ce moment là les 30 députés
qui composaient cette commission
denquête entendu plus de 220 personnes
ils se sont permis de bousculer les
experts judiciaires les psychiatres et
des psychologues et ça je dirais c'était
une que l'on dira une initiative
politique je dirais noble vous année
encore la république vous et vous êtes
garant des libertés vous avez un rôle
très important
c'était une première parce comme pour
une petite équipe comme lcp elle
affrontait un événement politique
considérable
cette commission denquête a marqué
l'histoire parlementaire et judiciaire
et lcp au milieu de cette affaire c'est
ça qui est fantastique
[Musique]